let's talk about the Trump Republican
tax plan okay the Trump Republican tax
plan is working its way through the
House and Senate and it is a wily tricky
little thing and as you probably know
the broader pitch from Trump during his
campaign was hey I'm gonna do new I'm
gonna do tax reform and it's going to be
good for the little guy it's going to be
good for the middle class it's gonna
lower taxes for most people and really
that's been the Republican pitch
Republicans that have run for any office
for decades at this point have been
talking about how they will lower taxes
for lots of people but especially the
middle class and we know that the Trump
tax plan Trump Republican tax plan as
proposed will mostly lower taxes will
most significantly lower taxes for the
very rich and we already knew from
previous analyses that have been done
that the Trump Republican tax plan would
also add to the national debt by about
1.7 trillion dollars over ten years and
that's above and beyond other debt
increases that are coming there have
been some rightists who have said hey
that's going to be a slower increase of
the debt than we saw under President
Obama
no no no the Trump tax plan alone would
add 1.7 trillion to the debt that is on
top of all of the other debt increasing
deficits that we are dealing with but
the tricky thing has been that because
of how this Trump Republican tax plan a
bill is written it's been tough to say
for sure how many people in the long run
will have a tax increase or a tax
decrease and the reason that this has
been different is because the Trump tax
plan not only changes brackets the tax
brackets that exist which which is sort
of like the the top level tax rate that
people pay but the Trump tax plan would
also eliminate some deductions it would
eliminate some exemptions it would make
a variety of different changes and
Republicans have been going around
saying well listen most people are going
to be in a lower tax bracket and that
may well be true but in order to really
figure out
are people going to have a long-term
effective increase or decrease in the
tax rate that they pay you need to
account number one for the deductions
and exemptions that are being eliminated
but also some of the provisions in the
Trump tax proposal the Trump Republican
tax proposal expire so you might be
moved to a lower tax bracket and there
might be some other advantages gained
from the Trump tax plan in the short
term but some of those provisions will
expire and you might end up in the long
term actually paying a higher tax rate
well we now have an analysis of this the
Tax Policy Center has done a very full
and very thorough analysis and it turns
out that not ten percent not twenty five
percent not thirty three percent not
forty or forty five percent but more
than half of all American taxpayers more
than fifty percent of taxpayers will end
up in the long term paying higher taxes
once the temporary provisions of the
Trump Republican track tax cut proposal
expire leaving just the permanent
changes in place this analysis that that
alone is a major headline right and
because we have constant scandals
unfortunately too many voters will never
get this message the analysis that was
done by the Tax Policy Center also
explode exposed another flat-out lie
from Republicans I mentioned just a
couple minutes ago that the Trump
Republican tax plan has been scored and
it will add one point seven trillion
dollars to the debt over 10 years now
Republicans have been saying hey that's
okay because it might add one point
seven trillion although we don't really
believe that number but they'll concede
it'll add something to the debt but it's
going to generate according to some
Republicans one point five trillion in a
new revenue so their argument is it's
actually revenue neutral because we
think one point seven trillion is
exaggerated but will gain one point five
trillion from new revenue wrong this
analysis from the Tax Policy Center says
that actually the Trump tax plan will
generate a hundred and sixty nine
billion in new revenue over ten years
that is under 17 billion dollars per
year it is a drop in the bucket and it
is only one tenth of what Republicans
are going around touting so we're very
quickly learning that every aspect of
this tax plan is a lie to hide the
reality that it's a handout to big
corporations it's a handout to the very
rich and I realize that you always can't
just reduce reduce reduce taxes right
I've been telling you that and hopefully
you know by now that that it doesn't
work the math of it doesn't work but
Republicans have been campaigning on it
for decades what happened to we will
lower taxes for most people there was
this guy named Grover Nordquist he's
still alive but I mean he's not as
prominent anymore and he used to have an
organ an anti-tax organization I don't
remember the name of it and they would
demand that Republicans running for
House or Senate seats sign a pledge that
they would never raise taxes under any
circumstances what happened to that
attitude I guess now it's okay because
these are big big handouts to the very
rich and to corporations and I'm not
even because in the interest of time I'm
not even opening up the can of worms
about how our tax money is spent right
that's a whole other issue one issue is
what promises have Republicans made
about taxes and what are they now doing
number two is what is the morality and
ethics of cutting taxes for the very
rich and increasing them for a majority
of all Americans and then of course is
the conversation about how our tax money
is spent but that will have to be a
conversation for a different day more
lies more broken campaign promises but
hey Trump will be out of office when
most Americans taxes increase so at
least he's got that going for him pretty
convenient right I send me your thoughts
about this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is also on twitter at david
pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by health IQ you know you save
money on your car insurance if you're a
good driver so why not save money on
your life insurance if you lead a
health-conscious life after all if
you're physically active you have a
lower risk of all-cause mortality lower
risk of heart disease lower risk of
cancer mortality and what health IQ does
is reward you by using science and data
to get you a lower rate on life
insurance and this includes people who
are runners cyclists strength trainers
and more 56 percent of health IQ
customers save between four and thirty
three percent on their life insurance
and these are savings exclusive to
health IQ to see if you qualify get your
free quote today at health iq.com slash
Pakman one more time that's health
iq.com /p a que ma n get your free quote
today